[Musica]
[Applauso]
quello che vedete dietro di me è uno dei
miei libri preferiti di quando era una
bambina Barbapapà artigiano ho perso il
conto delle ore in cui ho sognato
guardando i vari barbacosi come
interpretavano i diversi modi di fare
artigianato e chi faceva la tessitura
che faceva la battitura del ferro chi
soffiava il vetro e io da piccola
totalmente affascinata da questa
capacità trasformativa e creativa
dell'umano così bella raccontata dalla
famiglia Barbapapà
tutta questa fascinazione si è tradotta
nel fatto che praticamente oggi con le
mani non so fare nulla ma In un certo
qual modo sono diventata una sorta di
Vestale dell'Artigianato italiano e da
10 anni lavoro con loro entro Nei
laboratori Ascolto le loro storie e
prova a mia volta a raccontarle al
meglio in modo da trasmettere più
persone possibili la fascinazione per
questo mondo che è contemporaneamente
antico e così moderno
Un'altra cosa che ho imparato è il fatto
che è difficilissimo riuscire a vedere
il risultato finale quando il pensiero
l'idea ancora in luce contrariamente a
quanto faceva benissimo Michelangelo che
quando entrava nelle cave di marmo di
Carrara dove noi vediamo semplicemente
un pezzo di pietra Lui vedeva già
l'opera d'arte è finita
purtroppo noi comuni mortali non abbiamo
questa capacità e se vogliamo vedere
raggiunto un obiettivo un'idea che ci
siamo prefissi abbiamo bisogno di
passare per un processo un processo che
comprende principalmente tre fasi che
sono ideazione progettazione e
realizzazione
guarda caso queste tre fasi sono proprio
quelle che si verificano quotidianamente
da centinaia sono da migliaia di anni
Nei laboratori degli Artigiani Ma
attenzione quello che vediamo ho messo
in atto non è la tecnica in modo
pedissequo e ripetitivo sono bensì delle
pratiche che prevedono la capacità di
attivare
la voglia di trovare le soluzioni e
delle strategie di problem solving Ecco
perché un artigiano non vi dirà mai
questa cosa non si può fare ma dirà
sempre troviamo il modo di farla
questa capacità di
attuare le tecniche di problem solving
sembra sempre più interessante al giorno
d'oggi nel momento in cui ci troviamo
davanti a un mondo che stentiamo a
riconoscere in un momento storico in cui
tutte le nostre certezze vengono minate
dalle notizie che arrivano giorno dopo
giorno e in cui effettivamente
all'orizzonte non sempre rivedere
nessuno con delle risposte davvero
visionarie per rispondere alle domande
importanti che il futuro ci pone
Ecco perché per fortuna ci viene
incontro ancora il made in Italy quello
vero fatto delle piccole aziende
produttive che innervano il nostro
territorio e che pur nell'oggettiva
difficoltà in cui anche se si trovano
non smettono di ricordarci l'importanza
di rimettersi in gioco di attuare la
capacità creativa attraverso le tecniche
del pensiero creativo
Cos'è questo pensiero creativo è una
sorta di occhiale che ci permette di
vedere soluzioni là dove gli altri
vedono solo dei problemi tipo la mia
cinturina che abbiamo inventato adesso
per fissare la cosa perché non sapeva
dove mettere Grazie
tutto ciò però ci porta a dire che cosa
che purtroppo questo pensiero creativo
che sarebbe così utile non soltanto in
campo lavorativo ma in qualsiasi momento
della nostra esistenza nessuno ce lo
insegna Questo è il vero problema e di
conseguenza non sappiamo nemmeno
riconoscerlo né tantomeno metterlo in
atto Quando ne abbiamo bisogno
Ecco perché mi sembra un'ottima idea
invitarvi a conoscere meglio questo
mondo diventando di entrare nei
laboratori degli Artigiani prendiamo ad
esempio il classico foglio di carta
quella di produzione industriale che
utilizziamo tutti i giorni
Proviamo per scontato senza renderci
conto che questo foglio in realtà è il
risultato di un lunghissimo processo di
studio e di tentativi di realizzazione
che si sono succeduti nel corso di
migliaia di anni qui dentro c'è la
storia della produzione artigiana della
carta che parte 3000 anni fa in Cina
passa attraverso Le Cartiere medievali
italiane e arriva sulla nostra scrivania
di oggi
questo stessa attitudine
al studio e alla sperimentazione la
vediamo anche nel lavoro del liutaio
sempre alla ricerca dei legni migliori
per ottenere un determinato suono dello
strumento che sta creando
così come anche nel laboratorio di
tessitura che si sforza di trovare uno
strumento efficace per rendere anche sul
tessuto prodotto al telaio quel disegno
meraviglioso disegnato sulla carta e
come anche nel laboratorio del ceramista
che a partire da un baffo di Lepre crea
lo strumento che non c'era per tracciare
quella linea che altrimenti non sarebbe
riuscito a fare un qualsiasi strumento
industriale
Se molte altre sono tantissime
esperienze che ci permettono da un lato
di renderci conto come viene attuato il
pensiero creativo dall'altra ci
permettono di capire l'importanza che
queste parti possiedono all'interno di
quello che è il patrimonio culturale Ma
lo sapete che il teatro dei pupi
siciliano è stato definito dall'unesco
come bene
immateriale dell'umanità insieme al
teatro siciliano molte altre arti che
purtroppo oggi però sono a rischio
perché sempre meno persone scelgono di
lavorare in questo campo
abbiamo parlato di un onesto quindi è
inevitabile parlare di cultura e di
domandarci quanta attinenza abbia il
mondo dell'Artigianato artistico con la
cultura in effetti l'artigianato in
questo paese è sempre stato considerato
a cavallo tra il mondo della produzione
e il mondo dell'arte ma non soltanto
nell'idea di cultura che abbiamo oggi in
quella che è sempre stata l'idea di
cultura nel nostro paese e torniamo a
scomodare i grandi del passato che
stasera si rigireranno nella tombe e
parliamo pensiamo di Leonardo da
Leonardo da Vinci a Michelangelo a
Raffaello ma anche a Galileo Galilei Sì
studiamo la loro storia ci rendiamo
conto che erano persone che prima di
tutto sapevano lavorare la materia
sapevano utilizzare gli strumenti e
quindi in primo luogo erano artigiani
sono poi erano pittori architetti
inventori e scienziati
erano di personaggi polieddrici in grado
di attuare il pensiero creativo il
pensiero divergente per offrire delle
soluzioni rivoluzionarie che hanno
lasciato il segno non soltanto nella
loro epoca ma anche nel futuro il nostro
presente e io mi chiedo Ma quanto
sarebbe utile se non indispensabile
anche oggi tornare a dare valore a
figure di questo tipo a figure che sanno
leggere in modo critico gli errori del
passato e trovare delle risposte davvero
innovative per rispondere a quelle che
ci pone il futuro di domani
Ecco che
ci rendiamo conto di questa cosa sono
personaggi
trasversali che sono in grado di
utilizzare tutti gli strumenti a loro
disposizione compreso oggi quello del
digitale che permette di stringere nuove
alleanze a livello globale a livello
internazionale attivando delle dinamiche
e delle dialettiche relazionali
l'aspetto relazionale In effetti sembra
essere strategico per l'artigianato è
quello che ci ricorda anche Richard Sant
nel suo libro The
krabsmanti dice il laboratorio è da
sempre un luogo sociale È un luogo dove
si stringono dei vincoli tra le persone
Ecco a me non piace chiamarli vincoli
preferisco chiamarle relazioni e forse
non soltanto tra le persone
In effetti forse il primo piano
relazionale con cui l'artigiano si trova
a dover fare i conti è quello con la
materia da sempre un rapporto di odio
Amore una sfida continua che però è
quella che ha portato alla creazione
all'innovazione delle pratiche e delle
tecniche artigiane così come le
conosciamo oggi
quando i ceramista estrae dal forno i
pezzi che ha messo a smaltare a cuocere
dopo averli smaltati non è mai veramente
sicurissimo di quello che troverà
aprendo la porta è vero che la sua
esperienza permette di definire con un
grado molto alto di approssimazione
quello che sarà il risultato finale Ma è
vero anche che non è mai sicuro di
trovarsi davanti un piccolo disastro o
una meglio meravigliosa sorpresa ma
quello che mi chiedo è che non è forse
questo il bello del fatto a mano
Non è forse questa la lezione che ci
insegna
l'artigiano è sì un demiurgo che dà
forma alla materia ma è
contemporaneamente consapevole del fatto
che comunque lasciarle un margine
decisionale e questo margine decisionale
che lascia È forse quello che ci dà il
senso del mistero e il fascino
dell'oggetto artigianale E forse in
questo equilibrio così conflittuale che
sia esplica la bellezza del prodotto
artigiano che ci regala sempre la
bellezza e la sorpresa dell'indefinito
abbiamo parlato di arte abbiamo parlato
di cultura inevitabile è allargando lo
sguardo arrivare a parlare di territorio
e delle relazioni che intrattiene con il
comparto turistico un aspetto che forse
viene molto spesso dimenticato è
l'importanza che le aziende artigiane
rivestono per questo comparto come
elemento attrattivo sia per le grandi
destinazioni che per i centri minori
per esempio a Venezia tra i tanti
ricordo la famiglia di battiloro
Menegazzo che producono questa
incredibile sfoglia d'oro ancora
realizzata a mano gli ultimi in Europa
Se passiamo a una destinazione media
come Perugia troviamo il laboratorio
Tessile bozzetti le cui imprenditrici da
decenni non solo esportono i preziosi
manufatti realizzati al telaio ma
raccontano anche sia nel loro
laboratorio che attraverso i loro
prodotti buona parte della storia
artistica e dell'identità produttiva di
Perugia e dell'Umbria
per arrivare fino al piccolo panificio
Lucano che si occupa di creare il pane a
partire dai grani antichi e prodotti
localmente ma anche di recuperare questi
oggetti che sono timbri del Pane degli
strumenti che testimoniano la storia
dell'antropologia della vita di campagna
della Lucania e che venivano usati una
volta per timbrare la propria pagnotta e
poterla poi riconoscere una volta uscita
dal forno comune
Questa stessa
importanza dell'identità culturale La
riconosciamo Dunque anche nel prodotto
gastronomico Sappiamo benissimo che in
Italia ci sono feste religiose ritte
apotropaici ricorrenze familiari che
vengono festeggiate attraverso i
prodotti gastronomici creati apposta per
quella specifica occasione Penso ad
esempio alla frutta Martorana siciliana
o ai coricando sardi o ancora al San
Martino di Venezia o ai tanti diversi
prodotti Pasquali o per i morti che
vengono realizzati un po' ovunque Questo
prodotto gastronomico è sicuramente un
modo meraviglioso di conoscere le
tradizioni la storia L'arte di un
territorio
Ecco perché è utilissimo
utilizzare i sensi per conoscere un
territorio Quindi il gusto l'olfatto e
la vista vista perché l'aspetto estetico
è altrettanto importante in questi
prodotti gastronomici E beh nella
recepito il mondo di social media che ha
visto in questi anni svilupparsi una
serie di profili che raccontano le
curiosità del prodotti gastronomici come
in questo caso pasta granny che racconta
appunto le curiosità della pasta fatta a
mano
e Siccome sappiamo che la curiosità
muove l'informazione e che le dinamiche
turistiche si nutrono del Passaparola
non solo digitale ma anche analogico
materico fisico Ecco che negli ultimi
anni il laboratorio artigiano è
diventato il luogo di incontro tra il
design innovativo il prodotto
tradizionale e l'identità locale
risultato di questo incontro è una
capacità di raccontare il territorio in
chiave contemporanea e anche dei
souvenir narrativi ad alto contenuto
culturale
ci sono tanti esempi in questi anni che
sono usciti Mi piace ricordare il signor
artigiano tra gli altri in Val Camonica
Ma questa sera vorrei raccontarvi la
storia delle brocche della Val di Ledro
sono dei chiodi come vedete che sono
stati usati per tantissimi anni per
chiodare gli scarponi dell'esercito
austro-ungarico La Valle di Ledro è qui
in Trentino e da sempre nota per la sua
capacità lavorativa del metallo oggi
Ovviamente questi oggetti non vengono
più realizzati con quello scopo ma sono
rimasti come elemento identitario molto
forte della Val di Ledro Ecco perché
qualche anno fa è stato lanciato un
concorso che si proponeva di come dire
ripensare questo oggetto in chiave di
souvenir territoriale il progetto
vincitore lo vedete qui dietro e Brocchi
fondenti delle designer Monica Maggi che
trovo particolarmente interessante
perché cambiando uno dei fattori della
produzione la materia prima e quindi
passando dal crema al cioccolato è
riuscito a mantenere come dire
l'estetica esterna uguale a prima ma a
dare una funzione completamente diversa
al prodotto Ma perché è così importante
che il turista entri in relazione con un
souvenir narrativo di questo tipo Beh è
semplice perché diventa un tassello
fondamentale del grande mosaico della
comunicazione del territorio in chiave
identitaria e culturale
Quindi abbiamo parlato delle relazioni
con il turista ma nel laboratorio
artigiano non è l'icona relazione tra
umani che si sviluppa c'è l'apprendista
c'è il fornitore cioè il cliente c'è il
collega in ognuno di questi incontri si
sviluppa un dialogo attivo e creativo
che porta alla realizzazione del miglior
prodotto possibile in termini di
equilibrio tra quello che è il desiderio
e quella che è la fattibilità quindi è
ben vedere il fare artigiano ci ricorda
l'importanza delle relazioni tra le
persone come strumento di evoluzione non
soltanto del Fare progettuale ma anche
della società nel suo complesso
l'artigianato ci riporta in modo
rivoluzionario alla luce la necessità
dell'umano come centrale anche nel
mercato in un'epoca storica in cui ci
hanno convinto che l'efficienza e
l'ottimizzazione economica siano le
uniche strade percorribili
questa centralità dell'umano c'è la
sfida molto bene Giancarlo stampatore di
Vicenza
mia nonna mi ha lasciato in eredità non
solo questa bottega e il saper fare di
stampatore ma soprattutto la
consapevolezza che il vero obiettivo del
mestiere dell'Artigiano è l'incontro con
l'altro nel mio caso con l'artista sono
nell'incontro con l'altro si esplicano
quelle
attitudine del DNA artigiano di cui il
laboratorio è ottima palestra di
esercizio ecco dunque che il laboratorio
artigiano non è solo storytelling ma è
veramente il luogo dove si mettono in
pratica le migliori energie di cura e di
crescita delle relazioni con l'altro con
la materia e con il territorio
territorio che abbiamo capito A questo
punto essere per l'artigianato sia
nutrimento sia contemporaneamente un
frutto a livello di
degli eventi culturali
antropologici e produttivi
prendo prestito ancora le parole di
Giancarlo per ricordare come
l'artigianato sia Sì fatto di regole ma
a volte queste regole possono essere
dimenticate E nel momento in cui
fantasia e improvvisazione prendono il
sopravvento rendono ogni progetto non
solo più magico ma anche più possibile
non mi resta che salutarvi augurandomi
augurandovi di rendere più magico e più
possibile anche Ogni vostro progetto
Grazie e buon viaggio nell'artigianato
italiano
[Applauso]